Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P, so many of you calling in about the
Trump town hall on CNN.
Most of you were appalled.
Let's listen to a couple of these voicemails.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Hi, David.
I just have to say about this Trump thing.
Tonight on CNN, I'm about 38 minutes into
it and having to.
Pause, walk outside and de-stress every 10
minutes or so.
But.
Saying that CNN did.
Here is the crowd.
The crowd is for the second.
That's right.
It's like a laugh track.
Absolutely.
I mean, you have Caitlin Collins, who I honestly
you know, I looked at this tonight and I heard
your you know, I listen to your live stream
and I heard your show earlier today.
And I'm thinking to myself, the biggest person,
you know, that's got everything on the line
is that Trump?
It's Kate Collins.
And she's trying to interview this man.
Where the crowd is literally a laugh track
from the 1960s.
I don't understand why CNN put their own employee
in this position.
Speaker 1: But yeah, so this is this is part
of the argument I made about Kaitlan Collins.
You know, there is praise and criticism of
Caitlyn Collins, but putting her in that position
with a sycophant crowd is part of the friendly
nature in total with which Trump was given
this opportunity.
Let's listen to another caller about the Trump
town hall.
I think this is the ag man.
Speaker 4: I watched Trump and Kaitlan Collins
on CNN last night like it was a homework assignment.
Yeah, I watched it like I had to do it because
it was something I needed to report on.
My wife was watching with me.
She walked out of the room.
It upset her so much.
You can't stand Trump that much.
You couldn't even listen anymore.
But I forced myself to watch.
I can't wait to hear what you have to say.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: John column the man quite appalled
by it.
And here's one more caller weighing in.
Speaker 4: Hi.
Yeah, Dave.
Semi longtime listener of maybe less than
a year.
I've watched the drums or listened to the
Trump Town hall and it was pretty.
Within 5 minutes of listening, I was just
like, This is a waste of time.
I mean, I get why CNN did it.
I mean, but we didn't learn anything about
Trump that we didn't already know.
Speaker 1: That's true.
But we learned a lot about the state of Trump
sycophants, because when you look at when
the crowd laughed and when the crowd cheered,
it was at the absolute bottom of the barrel
moments when Trump attacked his own sexual
assault victim.
During the event, the crowd laughed and cheered
when Trump attacked the moderator, Kaitlan
Collins.
The crowd laughed and cheered when Trump said
he actually won in 2020.
The crowd cheered.
The crowd was actually what was new.
Trump did his greatest hits, and it was truly,
truly horrible.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about the latest out of the Supreme
Court.
We're going to talk about Fox News hit with
yet another defamation lawsuit.
And we will also talk about Senator representing
California Dianne Feinstein's return to the
Senate for the first time since February amid
calls for her to resign.
We'll discuss the entire circumstances around
her return, all on the bonus show.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
Your lucky stars every day.
You're not Dave Bachman.
Speaker 1: You don't have to be me to listen
to the bonus show or to watch it.
I'll host it.
You watch it.
Sign up and join Pacman Icon.
Otherwise, we'll be back tomorrow.
Unidentified: With a brand.